PROFESSOR: Hi, my name is
Nicole and welcome to
recitation.
Today we are going to go over
the practice problem for the
nucleic acids, carbohydrates,
and lipids section of the
biochemistry module.
First, if you haven't had
a chance to look at this
problem, please go back and look
at it and then come back
to recitation and we'll
go over it together.
Welcome back.
To start this problem, we are
going to go through parts A
through D and then we'll take
a break and come back and do
parts E and F.
So, this problem asks us about
the molecule shown here.
First, we are asked to
name this molecule.
By looking at this molecule,
it's really easy to figure out
what it is.
All you have to do is notice
the fatty acid tail and the
phosphate head.
If you remember from lecture,
this should tell you that it
is a phospholipid.
Next, we are asked where we find
these molecules in living
cells and what the function
of these molecules is.
So if you remember from lecture,
we are told that we
find these molecules
in cell membranes.
We learned that they are an
integral part of cell
membranes and their function is
to control the permeability
of the cell, which is a very
important function.
Their structure allows them to
keep out polar molecules and
let in nonpolar molecules so
they can allow the cell to
have a high solute concentration
on the inside as
compared to the outside.
So their critical function is to
form a permeability barrier
on the cell.
So now that we understand what
the function of these
molecules is, this question asks
us what would happen if
we dropped these molecules
into a glass of water.
So sometimes these molecules
are drawn like this, with a
circle as the phosphate
head and two squiggly
lines as the tail.
So if we dropped these in
water, we can get three
possibilities.
Either they can form a micelle,
which is drawn with
all of the heads towards the
outside, facing the water
molecules and the tails all
hidden on the inside.
Or, it can form a liposome,
which is two layers with a
very tight layer of
phospholipids on the inside
and a larger layer of
phospholipids on the outside
with the tails facing inwards
and the heads facing outwards
towards the water.
And there is also water
in the middle as well
facing these nonpolar--
I mean, these polar heads.
The third structure they
can form is a bilayer.
This is a structure that is
found that makes cell
membranes, is this phospholipid
bilayer.
So this is actually a much
larger structure--
I've only drawn part
of it here--
and this is where you have water
on both sides of it.
So you have water molecules out
here and on the inside of
the bilayer.
So those are the three
molecules that--
three structures that this
molecule will form when you
drop it into water.
Now the most important part of
this problem is asking why do
these molecules form these
structures when
dropped into water.
And we can find the answer to
this very easily in just
looking at the properties
of phospholipids and the
properties of water.
If you look at a phospholipid,
you'll see that the head, the
phosphate head, is negatively
charged, so that means that
it's polar, whereas the tail is
a fatty acid, and we have
learned that that means
that it is nonpolar,
because it has no charge.
And if you look at
water, water is a
polar molecule as well.
It has two polar bonds
to hydrogen.
And the reason that they form
these structures is because
the polar heads of the
phospholipids want to interact
with polar water and the
nonpolar tails of the
phospholipids do not want to
interact with the polar water.
So they have to find the
confirmations in which the
tails are hidden from
water and the heads
are exposed to water.
So now that we understand why
phospholipids form these
structures, we're going to take
a break and come back to
the second part of
the problem.
Welcome back.
Now we are going to solve parts
E and F of this problem.
Part E asks us to draw another
molecule that contains
phosphate that is essential
to biological systems.
Right off, you should be
thinking about nucleic acids.
I have written an example of
a nucleic acid up here.
This, as you can see by the A in
the base position, is ATP.
And you can see where phosphate
is essential as the
triphosphate portion of ATP.
The next part of the question
asks us what is the function
of these type of molecules?
So the molecule that I chose
to draw, ATP, is very
interesting because it has
multiple functions.
It serves as a building block of
RNA through oligomerization
through this bond by
adding multiple
nucleic acids together.
It also serves as an energy
source for the cell, the
energy source for the cell,
through breaking of this bond,
which is an exergonic reaction
and releases energy and allows
a lot of the processes in the
cell that wouldn't normally be
able to occur to occur.
So I'm going to put as a
function of this molecule as
both energy and RNA.
So now that we understand the
properties of phospholipids
and we've been able to
identify another very
important molecule that contains
phosphate, we can
move on to the rest of the
biochemistry section.
In this problem, we have learned
about the properties
of phospholipids as well as the
importance of phosphate in
nucleic acids.
I hope you've enjoyed watching
this video and I hope to see
you next time.